[Applause]
we were
trying to have a very um intellectual
discussion about how
large we would like our daughter's
breasts to be now before you judge us
for this discussion you have to
understand we want what is best for our
children we want them to have the
easiest life
we want them to have the best
opportunities in life you send your kids
a private school why
so you get a great education so they go
to a great school get a great job
succeed
well what if having
a great set of tits opened up just as
many possibilities for that
daughter of yours as going to a
uh you know great institution to get
educated
why not do both why not do both why not
give your daughter
everything you could possibly want it
was motivated by this trump clip where
trump was like
you know someone asked about his newborn
daughter i think it was tiffany
and they're like what is tiffany favor
you or
your wife marla maples and he was like
well i think it's mostly
marla she's got marla's legs and then we
don't know if she has marlo's
tits he basically grabs his boobs and
everybody's like oh my god what a pig
but
even though he's joking it is an
interesting discussion
how big would you want your daughter's
breasts to be you don't want your
daughter to be ugly
correct correct mundo can't have an ugly
daughter
absolutely why not because there's
limited opportunities in an ugly
daughter
she can't do as much with ugly as she
can with pretty that's true
the fact al i'm shallow and i'll love
her less
you're shallow you'll love her less that
is that [ __ ]
that's one take all feelings no facts
that's an interesting thing like i don't
think i'd love her less but i'd
be less affectionate
yeah that's what i mean like you know i
mean
no i wouldn't be less i feel like i
would love her more
like i would force myself to love her
more oh to like make up for it yeah
nobody else can't believe
i think if i only had an ugly daughter
yeah i'd be grateful that like i kind of
got a son
what do you mean by that like you find
an ugly daughter look like a guy i'd be
like
all right that's cool i finally got oh
oh okay
you had one kid yeah if you only had one
kid it had to be a girl you'd rather an
ugly girl i'd rather either way it's
like
it can work either way if it's a hot
girl you're like all right cool got a
hot girl if it's an ugly girl you go
all right she'll be good at sports right
so you're going to see glass half full
with your ugly ass kit
yeah so okay do you think it's possible
that what
come on son al you have mad
opportunities to have daughters already
bro we
but al is okay listen i think you gave
the honest answer we're going all
feelings no facts i'm gonna love the
[ __ ] out of my daughter
my ugly daughter if i have one but
i think i'm gonna give her a complex
what's that
because she's going to think she's more
beautiful than yeah then the world going
to kick the [ __ ] out of her
yes you know what i fear [ __ ] you know
wait a minute but think about that
go ahead isn't that worse way
worse nah cuz i think somebody will love
that ugly [ __ ]
no dude i know girls i know girls that
like are having a lot of trouble dating
this is this is [ __ ] up this is kind
of sad
because like a barna from indian
matchmaking what
like aparna from indian matchmaking
which one was she she was the [ __ ] the
lawyer in houston oh my god exactly
everybody 100 100 right typical girl
thinks she's better than she is right
she's surrounded by [ __ ] boys right
you hear these girls say they say every
guy's a [ __ ] boy every guy's a [ __ ]
boy no
unfortunately and this is [ __ ] up say
these guys think they're out of your
league
and you think you're out of the guys
leagues that are in your league
so you don't give them a chance and you
just [ __ ] with these guys who are just
using you for some buzzing you're not
ready for the big leagues andrew out
here
talking that's right this is this might
be facts and feelings
[ __ ] go back down to double a like your
small ass tits
yo that was great but for real yeah that
is this very interesting right so now
and i've seen girls do this they're so
frustrated with men
and i think they might be filled up with
this
idea of themselves that isn't true and
it's rewarded by ins by their social
media by instagram they know how to hit
the angles and [ __ ]
they got all these indian dudes
commenting on that yeah we'd be doing
that
so we'd be doing that [ __ ] bro mark was
working on a joke about it i don't want
to give away the joke but it was really
funny but i sent him a picture this [ __ ]
was hilarious
it's indian dudes because indian dudes
are notorious from india
for commenting on girls instagram
pictures and facebook pictures about how
hot they are yeah and
i'll smell your feet i'll do anything
right right right these
these indian dudes were commenting on
what they did not know
was a painting that's a painting of a
naked girl
sweetie i love you i want to take you
forever i want to hit
it can i say this in defense of my
people at least they're asking
permission
that whoa that is true that's a progress
yeah i mean progress yeah little by
little yeah
you know what i mean anyway i see these
poor girls
and they're filtered up and they start
to believe what they see online and then
they're dating all these dudes and they
think every dude is a fuckboy no you're
just dating dudes that are out of your
league
now here's the [ __ ] up thing about
girls and here's the
[ __ ] amazingly uh what does it call
the
privileged or whatever that [ __ ] term
is people throw around about dudes
i can date out of my league yeah by
upping the [ __ ]
that i can control yeah right yep
i can get a better job i can be more
successful i could be great in my
industry whatever it is i could throw
darts the best dart throw in the world
there's gonna be a bishop of darts
and she gonna end up [ __ ] me let me
tell you something you brought up last
week though
that as women are getting more
successful the really successful women
are doing the same [ __ ] dudes do
because they don't need anything from
the dude the secure women they get so if
you got a daughter you raised her is she
ugly you gotta raise her to be a boss
[ __ ]
but i have one i have one counter
argument to that counter my friend
i think that applies after the women
have had children and have been married
right because it's still there's this
societal pressure for women
to get married and have kids like they
failed
if they don't get married and have kids
i agree yeah
right some people would agree yeah
feelings right
real talk we should we should all do
that [ __ ] right
gay ass leonardo campbell people are
upset that i call
you guys yeah but whatever yo you gay
too yeah they don't know they want to
[ __ ] them yet yeah not you the people
commenting no but you too
anyway so i think once they achieve that
yeah they got to get married they got to
have the kids they got to achieve the
societal expectations
then they could be down with their
[ __ ] right right but i think a girl
who hasn't achieved it
i think she feels that little chip on
her shoulder bro
and i think they're willing to get it
that's interesting like your girl wanted
that ring huh oh yeah
for what reason for what reason besides
everybody's been telling her since she's
a kid that she got it she just wants me
to spend as much money as humanly
possible that's what my theory is
as long as it's on her oh yeah yeah not
on your [ __ ]
i could buy my own [ __ ] but if i bought
myself more [ __ ] than i bought her she'd
be like what's happening that'd be
[ __ ]
balanced in the universe you've never
seen your girl protect your money like
she cares about you
yo i think it's never come up but
sometimes i'm like yo
i realize i buy too much [ __ ] because
she just forgets what money is
i'll say the price is something i've got
a couple thousand and she'll literally
go
is that expensive wait what do you mean
like i'll say some [ __ ] costs like a
couple thousand dollars and she'll be
like
is that is that expensive and i'm like
god damn you have not spent money in so
long you forgot that a comma is a lot of
money does she
does she does she uh not spend any of
her own money
it's all one account we're married but
really yeah
you complete access to whatever you buy
can be honest i'm lying we haven't done
it yet
[Applause]
he feels like he's all connected that's
why we've been dipping out of one
account this whole time
that's how it is yeah but it's gonna
it's gonna combine but so you're gonna
bring her little [ __ ] over to yours
yeah are you gonna be condescending
about it oh look at your cute little
money
drop top phone i think i have to to
remind her why she married me
you should spend her [ __ ] first oh you
should be like yo this is the difference
but we're going to take all your [ __ ]
out of here yeah yeah yeah cause then
she relies on you
yeah whoa for her livelihood i know this
is this is you need to keep her around
you know exactly
bro we can't have this [ __ ] dude you
can't have freedom like that yo you're
gonna start realizing you can do better
[ __ ] all that
but not for real man i wonder if we're
like
not preparing our kids right are you
gonna be real with your [ __ ] kid bro
are you gonna like say
i noticed this when i was in like in
spain that like
spanish people have a real understanding
of who they are and how they look
um like the girls that were like a seven
were like yeah i'm a seven
that's that's what i am it's cool and
they were happier right
and the dudes that i guess were like a
seven they're like i don't know well i
don't know spanish dudes
going after anything but like girls had
this real realistic approach to like who
they were and how attracted they were
and i don't know like americans we would
never do that
you tell your ugly [ __ ] kid they're
the most beautiful human being has ever
walked the face of the earth
al your puerto rican mom didn't say that
you're amazing you're perfect
yeah but never really commenting on my
looks like oh yeah
oh we be commenting but i don't know
she never said you're handsome bro yeah
i guess so i'm just not thinking about
it it's one of those words that are just
like uh yo it's all good
if your mom thinks you're busted bro
puerto rican bob thinks i'm an angel and
it's gonna stay there yeah that's
actually true though you know what angel
has nothing to do with attractiveness
that's true based on behaviorals are
supposed to be like the
ideal you don't even know what angel's
face looks like wearing that bag ass
cloak because they probably fat as [ __ ]
these angels
interesting bro that's why they need
them big ass wings angels are like
babies aren't they
mark a lot of times you just said they
got the body
no because that's valid because angel
soft toilet paper the
thing on the front is a baby that's what
i'm saying
what do you mean they're like babies in
the way that like they don't exist
around alex
i gave a lot of fetuses their wings
actually now you think about
i'm sorry man we're fighting for jokes
on this podcast
we thought trump's titty thing was going
to really rock today but
it hasn't it's three times are running
it back it was killing in the green room
let's talk about that [ __ ] getting shot
all right i don't know man
for real i'm just trying to prepare
ladies for the real world i don't know
how the best way to do it
i don't know if i keep it 100 with my
daughter but i'm like yo we got the same
nose yo that [ __ ] is pronounced
you better get funny
you better learn how to tell the story
sweetheart this is going to be
interesting
i wonder if we do that or if we
completely lie and they go through life
delusional what is there a way to love
her without telling her she's beautiful
is there so i mean this is i literally
we need a girl in this podcast bro
for real and you can't even get through
the sense
we need taylor taylor was supposed to
come in today should have been perfect
for this
i think what happens biologically when
you have the kid you automatically think
they're the most beautiful thing
every parent says oh my kids beautiful
and they'd be some ugly ass [ __ ] kids
oh that's what i'm saying i think you
it's like almost like beer goggles when
you have a kid
so you don't think your child goggles
beautiful so it's not even lying you're
going to say it sincerely
because you've been eating yours you're
going to love it no matter what
that is you're probably right yeah yeah
so now you were
oh [ __ ] so you gotta ask your homie like
i gotta come to y'all
and be like yo keep it a buck all right
technically your caps are a little wider
than i used
it's like a little bit of an underbite
right there she's drooling a lot i'm not
really into that you know i made these
diapers they just don't fit what
i'll just be like oh she looks a lot
like you is
she looks like that's not what we can't
do that mark
what you got to be you got because you
could look like [ __ ] them up
you could [ __ ] up a girl what do you
mean no no no i'm telling you you're
just saying to me if you're just saying
it to me oh
yeah do you want us to be honest with
you that's why i wonder
if i should come to you guys and go you
tell me what my daughter
is i can't do it i can't do it don't
don't ever ask me i wouldn't i'll do it
right now i'll do it right now
before i even have a kid yeah would you
want us to keep it real
with your kid bro that big [ __ ] brow
you got
it could come out look like a hammerhead
there's gonna be some tearing okay and
you got this brown structure
yo what size hat is this kid yeah no
it's uh
my cranium is is too large i think but
no but here's the thing
what do we do do we keep it on you say
no akash
you want me to lie to you yeah i know
your kid gonna be cute in the beginning
yeah that's actually kind of a tricky
thing indian and asian kids they're way
cuter
they're way cuter but when they grow old
bruh
that's that nuclear mutant i gotta worry
about how my girl looks at
60. i'm saying your daughter at 60 is
gonna be
though bro that i'm not gonna be back
your daughter at 60 i'm gonna be i'm
gonna be like 97
98 yeah y'all are probably gonna try to
have kids soon right yeah yeah
i'll be 97 98 yeah blind as [ __ ]
still be able to see how busted
[Applause]
no that i would never try to [ __ ] none
of y'all daughters bro no matter how old
i am that's foul that's
foul i don't even believe it
i get some head bro
i'm supposed to [ __ ] your daughter
that's what i'm supposed to say
who's your daddy no that's my best
friend
i know exactly who your daddy is known
for my whole damn life
i'm just saying you can't do that that's
a that's violation bro
maybe it's better whoa whoa
whoa you know how there's like some sort
of like uh
i'm sure we have some sort of like
biological inhibitor to like [ __ ] our
family members mm-hmm
you know like we probably find our close
family members even cousins we're like
you kind of look too much like it's a
hormone thing yeah is it a hormone thing
yeah
are you sure yeah so what happens like
they smell like you
yeah i'm pretty sure there's like like
you don't like the smell necessarily
you're not attracted to the smell that's
too close to you interesting and you
would have the same smell that makes
sense yeah i don't believe you because
he's been trying to [ __ ] his cousins
let me tell you one group of people he
is not trying to [ __ ]
he's staying as far away from his gut my
cousins
maybe that's why he don't [ __ ] black and
puerto rican because the families are
bigger and he's like what if i [ __ ] a
family member
that's always been a concern with
adopted people oh yeah
how would you feel about that what do
you mean if you were adopted would you
[ __ ] older women some [ __ ] like that
happened to t.o where like the first
girl he ever had a crush on
found out that was his half-sister oh my
gosh i remember this his dad
her dad came over was like yo you can't
because it was the neighbor yeah
and that's when he found out who his dad
was because he was like you're i'm
your father also but you got the
neighbor pregnant and then didn't move
yeah that's wild yes that's so foul
that's not a home record that's
the opposite i guess like yeah it's a
community building
as a homemaker i mean that's the ideal
way to raise a family if you've got a
side family
yeah literally honestly on your side
right over there inside the house yeah
dad i'm coming
finishing up dinner
you think that's like where he got the
speed from
his dad just running back and forth i
could see it if he was really good in
the first 10 yards
but his dad clearly ain't got no
distance speed before i got tired across
the street and i was like no let's just
sit up i'ma stay
yeah that is [ __ ] up i don't know man
i don't i don't know
i don't know it's a weird situation yeah
i don't want my kid to have be overly
hot
but not ugly you don't want your kid to
be stunningly beautiful
no yo actually maybe that's a good if
it's a if it's a dude
or a girl being too good-looking it's a
it's a
like a handicap it is because that's all
you rely on
not only that it's cause you think
they're [ __ ]
like good looking people my assumption
is they're dumb
yeah i don't look at good looking people
i'm like yo that guy's a [ __ ] genius
right right
that chick she got it
you